[Música]
la presidenta de Perú Dina boluarte hizo
nuevamente un llamado al congreso para
que apruebe el adelanto de las
elecciones presidenciales la mandataria
hizo la solicitud en una sesión de la
oea en donde pidió apoyo a los países
miembros boluarte prometió Investigar
los posibles casos de exceso de la
fuerza por parte de los militares
escándalo en el gobierno de ecuatoriano
una serie de audios revelan un supuesto
entramado de corrupción en las empresas
públicas del sector eléctrico que
salpican al círculo cercano del
presidente de Guillermo lasso entre
ellos a su cuñado tenemos informe desde
quito
la ONU insiste en que se necesita de la
ayuda de fuerzas internacionales para
ayudar a la policía de Haití a combatir
las pandillas el gobierno haitiano ha
solicitado dicho apoyo pero las
discusiones sobre qué país tomaría la
iniciativa siguen estancadas
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en Flash 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz ascendió a 59
la cifra de fallecidos que dejan hasta
el momento las manifestaciones
ciudadanas en Perú con la muerte de un
niño en cusco en la jornada de este
miércoles la presidenta Dina boluarte
mantuvo una reunión con sus homólogos de
los países que integran la oea a quienes
pidió apoyo para encontrar una solución
pacífica el gobierno peruano se mostró
abierto a iniciar investigaciones sobre
posibles casos de violaciones a los
Derechos Humanos entre tanto el malestar
social se mantiene en las calles no
pueden quedar impunes el gobierno de
Perú intenta cuidar su imagen
internacional
mientras que crecen las denuncias del
exceso en el uso de la fuerza por parte
de la policía contra los manifestantes y
se militariza regiones del sur la
presidenta Dina boluarte sostiene una
postura conciliadora ante organismos
internacionales este miércoles boluarte
pidió la ayuda de países amigos en
videoconferencia ante la Organización de
Estados Americanos oea para adelantar
las elecciones en Perú y lograr una
salida pacífica y prometió Investigar
las denuncias sin embargo el congreso
peruano rechazó un dictamen en diciembre
el año pasado que estipulaba la
celebración de elecciones presidenciales
en diciembre de 2023 con un apoyo casi
unánime los congresistas acordaron
postergar los comicios hasta abril de
esto aumentó la atención social en las
calles los manifestantes exigen la
renuncia de boluarte el cierre del
Congreso y el adelanto de elecciones
luego de que el expresidente Pedro
Castillo fuera destituido y detenido por
el delito de rebelión la señora de una
tiene que entender debe renunciar si
quiere tregua sin posibilidad de tregua
a corto plazo tanto los manifestantes
como el gobierno mantienen su postura
Dina boluarte atribuyó la reciente
violencia en Perú a algunos
organizadores de las protestas este
legítimo derecho de protesta no obstante
no puede significar que se permita
socavar las bases de la
institucionalidad democrática y de la
convivencia pacífica entre peruanos en
consecuencia con boluarte las
autoridades de la región de puno una de
las zonas más afectadas por la violencia
extendieron diez días más el toque de
queda
hay un escándalo que sacude al gobierno
ecuatoriano personas cercanas al
presidente Guillermo lasso entre ellas
su cuñado son señaladas de hacer parte
de un supuesto entramado de corrupción
en las empresas públicas del sector
eléctrico lazo por su parte descartó que
la corrupción se haya filtrado en su
gobierno previamente nuestro
corresponsal en Quito Gustavo Ortega nos
contó En qué consiste este escándalo Y
si podría tener algún efecto en el
gobierno a medida que se acercan las
elecciones locales
Sí buenas noches un escándalo que señala
al cuñado el presidente de la república
Danilo Carrera y de liderar una presunta
estructura de corrupción para favorecer
contratos públicos a través de El
sobornos De igual forma también se le
señala de Designar ministros en el
sector eléctrico esto ha tenido
denuncias en el Ecuador durante dos
semanas El Ejecutivo nacional ha
demorado mucho tiempo en responder Pero
ha sido poco a poco con declaraciones
contradictorias cuando el presidente de
la república Guillermo lasso ha emitido
reacciones y acciones luego de ciertos
audios que se han venido filtrando que
involucran ahí señalan a Hernán Luque
quien era el ex director de la empresa
pública coordinadora de todas las
empresas públicas de este país y a
Danilo Carrera su cuñado pero
posteriormente El Ejecutivo nacional ha
venido tomando acciones como solicitar
la renuncia de todos los directivos de
las empresas públicas del Ecuador pedido
también la captura de Hernán Luque Pero
estas dos personas fueron designadas por
el presidente de la república porque
fueron
sus compañeros durante el banco de
Guayaquil durante muchos años pero el
presidente de la república lo ha negado
en todo momento pero paralelamente
también se han conocido otros informes
de organizaciones del Estado Pero cómo
podría influir bueno Esto podría ser
mucho más competitivo y estrecho los
resultados de la próxima consulta del
reforma constitucional que se realizará
en este país el cinco de febrero y
también podría minar un poco la
credibilidad pero El Ejecutivo nacional
ha realizado una campaña para separar
así lo que ha sido la campaña electoral
separándola de el presidente Guillermo
lasso que en este momento maneja una
aprobación aproximadamente
el presidente brasileño Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva dijo que ve un posible
acuerdo entre el mercosur y China y de
esta manera muestra su apoyo a Uruguay
que ha estado promoviendo los
acercamientos comerciales con Beijing
sus palabras se dieron tras una reunión
con su homólogo uruguayo Luis lacalle
Montevideo la estrategia comercial del
gobierno uruguayo ha generado tensiones
dentro del bloque del que también hacen
parte Argentina y Paraguay Lula dijo que
es más que justo que Uruguay intenta
defender su economía
en México un juez frenó indefinidamente
la extradición de Ovidio Guzmán hijo del
narcotraficante El Chapo Guzmán Estados
Unidos la decisión Del magistrado
significa que el sujeto no podrá ser
trasladado a la espera de que se
resuelva un recurso presentado por el
mismo Guzmán para evitar su extradición
sin embargo deberá permanecer detenido
Washington que ofrecía 5 millones de
dólares por su captura acusa al hijo del
Chapo de narcotráfico
la enviada especial de Naciones Unidas
en Haití remarcó la necesidad de enviar
fuerzas internacionales Para apoyar a la
policía local en la lucha contra la
violencia de las pandillas la cual
provocó miles de muertes en 2022 y
propició bloqueos que generaron crisis
humanitarias y desabastecimientos rabino
cuevar venera nos cuenta más
Haití necesita ayuda internacional
así lo afirmó él en Lalín la enviada de
Naciones Unidas para el país caribeño
quien reiteró que sin las fuerzas
internacionales la policía local no
podrá hacerle frente a la violencia de
pandillera la cual dejó 2183 asesinatos
en 2022
saben que la situación en Haití es grave
saben que la violencia impulsada por
pandillas ha alcanzado nuevas alturas en
promedio enfrentamos un secuestro cada
seis horas en 2022
Necesitan ayuda necesita apoyo
la gente de Haití está sufriendo mucho
el pedido de la Lima refresca El
realizado por el secretario general
Antonio Gutiérrez en octubre pasado y
sucede Un día después de que Estados
Unidos y China propusieran incrementar
las sanciones contra los responsables de
la violencia urbana sin embargo la
enviada especial en Haití considera
necesario un esfuerzo mayor
podríamos actuar con más urgencia creo
que la comunidad internacional debe
hacerlo sin embargo se está considerando
activamente en este momento se discutió
en el Consejo de Seguridad y se está
discutiendo en la celac
no estamos haciendo lo suficiente para
poder ganar esta pelea en esta etapa ni
lo haremos sin niveles significativos de
apoyo adicional
el asesinato del presente de hecho Belén
moises en 2021 agudizó una ola de
diversas crisis en el empobrecido país
las pandillas propiciaron bloqueos que
generaron crisis alimentarias y
desabastecimiento en tanto que también
han surgido brotes de cólera un contexto
que lleva a miles de haitianos a buscar
la salida del país
[Música]
en Estados Unidos miembros de la
comunidad de Monterrey Park en
California se reunieron para una vigilia
A las afueras del estudio de baile donde
11 personas murieron tras un tiroteo con
velas y carteles y cientos de personas
llegaron para honrar y recordar a las
víctimas del fatídico hecho que se
produjo el pasado sábado por la noche
mientras se llevaba a cabo la
celebración del año nuevo lunar chino
el grupo Meta restauró las cuentas de
Facebook e Instagram del ex presidente
de Estados Unidos Donald Trump
recordemos que Trump fue eliminado de
estas redes sociales después del asalto
al Capitolio en la ciudad de Washington
el 6 de enero de 2021 tras dos años de
ausencia el ex mandatario volverá a
tener acceso a dichas redes la compañía
dueña de Facebook e Instagram argumentó
que el público debe poder conocer lo que
dicen los políticos para poder elegir
con conocimiento de causa
hasta aquí este Informativo en France 24
pero los invitamos a visitar nuestra
página web www.frans24
para seguir la actualización de nuestras
noticias Gracias por acompañarnos
quédense con nosotros
[Música]